Donald Trump has had the luxury of being the
owner and boss basically since the beginning
of his career.
And one of the great things about being the
and boss is that in a sense you can't get
fired.
Now I know that if you're the CEO of a publicly
traded company and there's a board of directors,
you might be the founder and you might be
the majority shareholder.
Um, majority of the, the plurality owner rather
not majority shareholder, but you might still
be forced to step down as CEO, for example.
And there are some cases in which you can
be the founder and the boss and still get
fired.
But in many situations outside of publicly
traded companies, you're effectively immune
from getting fired if you're the one in charge.
I can't be fired from the David Pakman show.
For example.
I'm the majority shareholder.
There's no board of directors.
Every paid member could quit.
Every viewer could stop watching.
We could end up with effectively no show.
I could just be sitting here doing videos
that nobody sees, but I can't be fired in
a sense.
And that is not typical in most jobs.
You're behavior on and off the job can get
you fired.
And I was thinking over the weekend that Donald
Trump's behavior at any other job where he
is not the owner of the company or the person
in charge would have absolutely gotten him
fired.
By now, Donald Trump has publicly insulted,
countless world leaders, sort of equivalent
to being our business partners.
We can say in a sense, if anybody ranging
from a low level employee to the CEO were
to publicly insult their company's clients
or their customers or their partners in the
way that Donald Trump has insulted the leaders
of other world, uh, uh, countries, they would
have been fired by now.
The highest law enforcement agencies in the
country did an investigation into Donald Trump
and they found substantial evidence of criminality
on eight of 14 possible obstruction counts
at any other job.
Those results from a criminal investigation
would obviously get you fired and most people
would also be indicted and facing prison time
right now.
But Trump's the boss or the owner or whatever
role he has as president of the United States
of America, he's apparently immune there as
well.
And then there's a whole other sort of angle
on this.
George Conway, who's an attorney and the husband
of Kellyanne Conway, who is one of Donald
Trump's closest advisors.
George Conway is a big Trump opponent.
And he pointed out something else, which is
that someone having the apparent mental health
issues that Donald Trump is having would also
have been let go from any other job based
on his behavior.
Tweeting over the weekend quote, you're not
presidential at all, period.
You're mentally unwell.
You engage in bizarre, irrational self defeating
behavior, which prompts criticism of view,
which triggers more bizarre, irrational self
defeating behavior.
You would have been fired from any other job
by now.
Trump's behavior is the type that would get
the bosses together to say, this person needs
to go, let's figure out how to get them out
of here with the least amount of drama possible
and we could actually go further.
If anybody exhibited Donald Trump's behavior
during the campaign, in the hiring process
for a job, they would never even get hired
in the first place.
And this is what happens when instead of a
three person hiring committee, including the
CEO, someone from HR and a supervisor gets
to decide who to hire when it's instead left
up to the American people, American voters,
60 million of whom are right wing Republicans.
This is exactly what you end up with.
Over the weekend I was talking to a friend
who's dealing with a very similar situation
at work.
They have a coworker who started writing outrageous,
aggressive emails including to their supervisors,
talking back to management, straight up saying
they're not going to be doing certain things
because as they see it, it doesn't make sense
to do it and telling the supervisors that
taking offense to anything that's said around
them and management is trying to figure out,
we need to get rid of this person, but we
also need to do it in a way that is not going
to create even more absolute and total chaos.
That's the distinction with Donald Trump.
Any normal person who behaved during the hiring
process, the way Donald Trump behave during
the campaign would not have been hired.
Any person who behaved at their job the way
Donald Trump has behaved since becoming president
of the United States would have been fired.
But the one advantage is we can just vote
Trump out.
Okay, people can just go vote and Trump has
to leave period.
In January of 2021 and my ask of you is the
following as atrocious and disastrous as Donald
Trump is.
We shouldn't forget that Trump is an effect,
not a cause.
Now, yeah, Donald Trump's presidency has caused
a lot of bad things.
He's ruined relationships with allies.
He's weaponized ignorance.
He's weaponized hypocrisy.
But Trump's presidency is the result of the
last 30 years, not a cause in and of itself.
So remember that getting rid of Trump doesn't
actually solve the problem, although it's
still something that we should do, uh, but
also understand the sort of proximate causes
that led to Donald Trump, which is exactly
what I want to talk about next on the show,
because it's so important and a lot of people
are missing the boat
on this.